[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue tant au point
de vue l'émission on en débat chaque jeu
chaude cette actualité elle est
aujourd'hui tragique après les deux
attentats de marseille et puis de las
vegas ce sera le premier sujet au
sommaire de notre émission alors que
l'état islamique via son agence de
propagande vient de revendiquer
l'attentât de las vegas affirmant que
l'auteur de la fusillade s'était
converti à l'islam informations qui ne
sont pas pour l'instant confirmée par
les autorités américaines nous allons
également reparler du référendum en
catalogne qui a eu lieu hier qui s'est
traduit par une majorité écrasante en
faveur de l'indépendance mais aussi par
de nombreuses échauffourées entre la
police espagnole et les manifestants
désireux d'aller exprimer leur point de
vue nous allons reparler de l'impôt sur
la fortune avec la réaction de françois
bayrou critiquant le fait qu' un certain
nombre d'objets de richesse soit
exonérées de cet impôt qui se retrouvent
réserve est pratiquement à l'immobilier
et puis nous parlerons de la journée
sans voiture qui a eu lieu à paris hier
était une formidable nouvelle pour
l'écologie ou une sorte de coup de force
légale de la maire de paris anne hidalgo
nous allons en parler avec nos 4 1 salut
bonsoir lucile flip vous êtes co
président de la fondation verte
européenne
votre dernier livre la france
résiste-t-elle à l'écologie est paru
l'année dernière vous avez été mais vous
l'êtes plus une élue du parti socialiste
et d'europe écologie les verts anne
fulda bonsoir vous êtes une des grandes
plumes du figaro on ne vous présente
plus vous êtes aussi l'auteur d'
emmanuel macron un jeune homme si
parfait qui est la biographie de
référence du président de la république
et qui est paru chez plon
bonsoir dominique reynié en soit vous
êtes directeur général de la fondation
pour l'innovation politique vous est
également professeur à sciences po et la
dernière étude de votre fondation qui
est basé sur une très grande enquête
dans 26 pays différents sera publié
cette semaine aux éditions plon ça
s'appelle où va la démocratie et le
figaro magazine a eu la joie d'en
révéler les extraits les plus forts dans
son numéro du week-end dernier et
bonsoir alexandre ii vecchio bonsoir
journaliste au figaro à la rubrique
débats opinion vous êtes le responsable
du figaro vox l'espace de deux débats et
de confrontations de points de vue du
figaro.fr vous êtes seul auteur des
nouveaux enfants du siècle paru aux
éditions du cerf je vous propose donc de
commencer par parler d'eux des attentats
l'attentât de las vegas mais surtout
l'attentât de marseille et je vous
propose de nous focaliser sur la
réaction des pouvoirs publics parce que
je pense qu'il est trop tôt pour
commenter ces deux événements dans la
mesure où on ne connaît pas encore
précisément le profil de leurs auteurs
présumés après la fusillade de las vegas
donald trump vient de dénoncer le mal
absolu a aidé auprès d abattre lors que
cet attentat a fait donc je vous le
disais au moins 50 morts et 400 blessés
dans un acte qui représente le mal
absolu a indiqué le président des états
unis tandis qu emmanuel macron lui aussi
avait réagi sur twitter
l'attentât de marseille profondément
indigné par cet acte barbare
je salue les militaires de sentinelle et
les policiers plomb le ministre de
l'intérieur lui aussi
réagissez sur twitter pour indiquer
qu'il se rendait immédiatement sur les
lieux tandis que le premier ministre
toujours sur twitter exprimé sa colère
et sa tristesse pour les victimes
soutien aux militaires et policiers du
sentinel qui nous protège a tweeté
edouard philippe
nous ne baissons pas la garde dominique
reynié les attentats se suivent et les
réactions sont toujours les mêmes on a
une espèce d'impression de déjà vu mais
aussi peut-être d'impuissance
certainement en face b
pour celui qui a eu lieu à marseille je
sait peu de choses sur celui qui a eu
lieu aux états unis aujourd'hui
mais pour marseille c'est le type
d'actes qui se dérobe à toute prévention
à toute forme d'anticipation nous sommes
dans des sociétés ouvertes donc par
définition poreuse et alors encore une
fois si jamais ça s'inscrit dans la
logique de l'attentât détermination dit
religieuse islamiste
c'est une autre façon de dire que nous
sommes dans un univers désormais
d'interconnexion où on peut être à
l'intérieur d'un espace protégé un
territoire national en relation avec des
idées qui circulent dans le monde et qui
vous amène à commettre l'irréparable
donc c'est vraiment une nouvelle donne
qu'il faut prendre en compte
et j'imagine que ça va ouvrir dans la
société il ne demande très forte de
contrôle d'autorité de surveillance
faudra veiller à ce qu on ne bascule pas
dans des sociétés où la liberté serait
de plus en plus limitées alexandre vécu
cette demande sera peut-être l'otan plus
forte que d'après ce que l'on sait
l'auteur de l'attentât de marseille
était un étranger en situation
irrégulière arrêtés à plusieurs reprises
et toujours remis dans la nature
oui j'allais venir pardo mais on est
très loin d'un état liberticide on est
plutôt en face d'un état défaillant je
rappelle quand même que la première des
libertés c'est la sécurité
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la plupart des
français la question qui se pose c'est
que faisait ce monsieur qui était en
situation régulière récidiviste sur le
territoire il ya un moment donné où
l'état de droit doit être respecté donc
je crois pas du tout qu'on est face à un
risque d' un état quasi dictatorial ou
trop autoritaire pour l'instant on est
face à un état qui est défaillant on est
certes dans une société ouverte mais je
crois que la mission des pouvoirs
publics' quand même de protéger les
citoyens il faudrait peut-être réfléchir
justement là où est ce qu'on met le
curseur entre l'ouverture totale et à un
minimum de fermeture pour nous protéger
je crois que c'est là la question de
fond que cet acte de la pause moi je
suis très inquiète de la banalisation
hier sur les chaînes d'info où on
parlait davantage de la violer en
catalogne on en reviendra peut-être mais
il me semble que là on est dans le
maintien de l'ordre et que finalement il
ya une certaine légitimité de l'état
exercer la force et de l'autre côté on
ne s'indigne pas qu'on puisse égorgés
éventrés des femmes dans la rue en
france donc je pense qu'il va falloir
trouver quand même le bon curseur entre
laxisme autorités justice mais moi
j'étais frappé l'expression qui a
employé emmanuel macron pourparlers pour
réagir à la tente un à las vegas
lorsqu'il a parlé de violence
contemporaine et j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait quelque chose d'assez fort dans
une manière de qualifier
je suis plutôt en accord avec ce que
vient de dire dominique reynié un
sentiment d'angoissé sur le fait de ne
pas pouvoir maîtriser les choses qui
vont arriver et en fait c'est peut-être
ça qui peut rapprocher ces deux
attentats sert le côté contemporain du
fait de se dire mais n'importe qui peut
devenir un terroriste moi c'est ça qui
me frappe
je sais pas comment il faut qualifier le
profil de ceux qui assassinent et qui
tue mais le sentiment qu'ils sont à la
fois peut-être des condamnés de droit
commun parfois effectivement des
migrants sans papiers parfois des
personnes
je rappelle que celui qui a tué à las
vegas était qualifié par son frère de
totalement normal donc parfois des
personnes qui peuvent être nos voisins
donc il ya quelque chose là qui est
profondément angoissant et je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il suffise de dire que l'état
a failli pour maîtriser cette question
de l' angoisse et ce problème qui à mon
avis dépasse largement les frontières
françaises
donc il peut y avoir là dessus des
réactions politiques en dix ans donc
quand on est dans l'opposition en disant
c'est de la faute du gouvernement
d'edouard philippe mais je crois que le
problème jeu
gouvernement c'est un évolution de fond
l'ouverture des sociétés mais quand même
c'est céline escalade parler les
attentats c'est pas le premier donc on
peut pas dire comme ça ça peut arriver
partout dans le monde pour qu'il ya une
forme de démission politique à à
banaliser ces choses là et à dire oui
cessé de la violence contemporaine ça
peut arriver un peu partout on baisse
les bras non là j'aimerais bien qu'on ne
comprenne ce que j'ai voulu dire dire
que c'est de la violence contemporaine
c'est à dire dire quelque chose qui
effectivement peut être un peu
conceptuel ne veut pas dire qu'on
banalise qu'on minimise ça veut dire que
celui qui pratique la violence peut être
peut-être votre voisin est quelqu'un que
vous n'imaginiez pas devenir un
terroriste pour des raisons qui peuvent
tenir au fait que vous changer
d'identité vous êtes quelqu'un au fond
d'un prévisible donc c'est
l'imprévisibilité la question du risque
que je voulais qualifier ainsi
c'est certainement le fait que de dire
qu' il faut baisser les bras même si
elle fait parler les français ressentent
peut-être pas les choses comme ça parce
que on leur dit ça pourrait être
n'importe qui mais il ya quand même des
profils pour l'instant et ces attentats
en tout cas celui de marseille comme les
précédents ils sont commis au nom d'anna
et on a l'impression que les politiques
on ne veulent pas trop aborder ce sujet
là moi je suis d'accord avec alex ans je
trouve qu'il ya une banalisation assez
inquiétantes de ces actes là c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on
on poignarde de femmes on égorge de
femmes avant et quand même effectivement
l'enquète n'est pas terminée c'est quand
même quelqu'un effectivement c'est
peut-être de la violence contemporaine
mais c'est d'accord néanmois sarce on ne
sait pas encore mais bon ça ressemble
quand même un acte terroriste
on attend de voir mais mais c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que on à dd comme
ça des actes peu partout dans le monde
qui qui survient il ya le sentiment
d'une espèce d'impuissance c'est vrai
qu'on sait pas trop comment réagir avec
aux états unis la différence concernant
la tuerie de las vegas c'est qu'il ya en
plus le débat sur la vente libre d'armes
puisque à priori le tueur avait dit
fusil avec lui et c'est vrai que c'est
pas qui a été très très soutenue pendant
toute la campagne dernière campagne
présidentielle est d'ailleurs hillary
clinton vient de réagir en disant qu' il
serait temps peut-être de changer de
position sur ce thème là alors c'est
vrai que nous n'avons pas ce nom mais le
débat là en france je crois qu'il faudra
pas vous mettre sur le même plan boys à
ce qui s'est passé aux états unis mais
en france on est très clairement visé
depuis depuis un certain temps
depuis 2015 au moins c'est quand même
pas le premier attentat s'il ya une
forme de répétition est effectivement le
profil on le connaît à peu près c'est
malgré tout il faut bien le dire souvent
une jeunesse d'origine immigrée qui est
désintégré culturellement et socialement
et qui se revendique d'une idéologie est
très particulière qui est celle de
l'islam radical alors on peut dire qu'on
ne sait rien sur le mode opératoire
porte quand même la signature de radical
et d'alès lalala revendiquer donc je
pense qu'il ya quand même deux problèmes
différents certes sans doute un problème
très particulier à la société américaine
qui est une société violente et les
armes circulent librement mais
aujourd'hui on a un problème d'
idéologie islamiste installé sur le
territoire souvent d'ailleurs des gens
qui viennent pas forcément de l'étranger
encore que la personne était en
situation irrégulière mais qui sont
désintégrées qui vont la haine de la
france et qui veulent détruire la france
pour pour ce qu'elle a pour sa culture
pour son identité donc je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs choses à faire a quand même
des mesures policières de bon sens je le
répète on ne comprend pas ce qu'est cet
individu faisait là c'est pas la
première fois qu'on a ce type de cas le
paiera mais on avait quelqu'un sous
bracelet électronique mais qui voulaient
partir en syrie à nice se rappelle
c'était encore quelqu'un en situation
irrégulière donc d'abord il ya un
problème policiers somme qu'il va
falloir régler et ensuite il ya un
problème idéologique auquel il va
falloir s'attaquer puisque c'est un
didier de la vienne deux sites et
détruisez communautariser et qui sont le
terreau finalement
du terrorisme même si l'islamisme ne
conduit pas d'autoroute au terrorisme il
en est le terreau et tant qu'on n'aura
pas à sécher ce terreau on n'en finira
pas donc les choses doivent être dites
une bonne fois pour toutes il ya des
mesures à prendre pour tracer petit
juste et faire un brin de veiller
craignais là dessus d'autant que
l'opinion publique européenne si on en
croise cette enquête à laquelle vous
allusion tout à l'heure et avec des sous
verres que vous avez mené pendant
quasiment toute l'union européenne
indique qu'effectivement il y a
vis-à-vis cette fois ci d'un point de
vue global vis-à-vis de l'islam et
vis-à-vis de l'immigration et pas
seulement vis-à-vis du terrorisme
un rejet des européens qui va croissant
oui c'est très net enfin il ya aucun
doute en termes de mesure les européens
considère l'islam comme
une religion dangereuse ont un problème
avec l'immigration parce qu'ils
considèrent que l'immigration c'est ce
qui fait entrer l'islam en europe avec
les problèmes liés à l'islam de conflits
interculturel sur toute une série de
sujets qui sont souvent abordés entre
les hommes et les femmes la liberté
d'opinion etc
la re le retour du religieux dans
l'espace public ça c'est aussi un
élément de temps à parler mais c'est
très important mais c'est très important
ce sont les mêmes européens qui
répondent ceux là qui disent le mois
dans les enquêtes on peut faire
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont intolérants
c'est à dire que sa voisine avec une
vraie tolérance exprimés et le souhait
par exemple conviennent qu on vienne au
secours des réfugiés qui sont en
difficulté des distinctions qui sont en
fait sont très importantes c'est pas un
jugement brutale de rejet comme on
pourrait le penser spontanément et comme
souvent d'ailleurs on stigmatise le
point de vue de ses citoyens en disant
racisme voire raciste c'est pas ça du
tout c'est une combinaison de très
grande tolérance à tout une forme
d'indicateurs qu'on a testé et qui font
certainement de l'europe l'espace plus
tolérants du monde
il faut aussi le rappeler le plus ouvert
qui sont très désireux d'accueillir des
personnes en difficulté parce que
réfugié ça c'est aussi mais qui ne
comprennent pas ce qui leur arrive une
fois que ces mouvements se produisent
avec ses retournements s'ils ont de
toute façon du commentaire d'un de faits
qui sont moi je suis un peu hésitant
parce qu'ils sont défaits que je
considère pour ma part comme encore
obscures même si le bourn a déjà deux
des éléments de toute façon on a des
problèmes avec des
français qui sont arrivés par l'islam à
des comportements dangereux mais je vous
précise aussi qu'à londres en 2005
les auteurs des attentats étaient des
britanniques qui étaient nés sur le sol
britannique
effectivement
converti à l'idée qu'elle était diplômé
très bien diplômés qui avaient des
métiers tout à fait confortable donc
c'est même la variable je vous dirais
social est compliqué à utiliser dans ce
genre de circonstances mais s'il suit
oui moi ce que je voulais dire c'est que
je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses à la
fois une vraie confusion
il ya évidemment la question du droit à
la sécurité tout à fait d'accord avec
vous là dessus il ya la question du
migrant qui n'est pas le français
musulmans il ya la question d'associer
les slams et le terrorisme ce qui
maintenant se fait de manière de plus en
plus spontané et là dessus le sujet
c'est au fond de réagir et d'élaborer un
discours politique lorsqu on est
musulmans ont concerné mais est-ce que
c'est pas quelque chose qui concerne
aussi j'allais dire le gouvernement la
classe politique dans son ensemble et
man moi je me rappelle quand même
d'autres sondages qui disait bien que
90% des musulmans français se sont el
haïk et donc il ya une espèce de
contradiction dans les termes qui nous
faut apprendre à traiter et ce qui
m'ennuie en fait dans le discours que
nous tenons ensemble c'est que nous
avons tendance à assimiler peut-être des
personnes qui individuellement ne se
ressemblent pas tant que ça et quand
même temps l'état islamique ne cesse de
revendiquer le moindre acte de violence
donc je trouve que il faut différencier
les choses mais j'observe que l'état
islamique revendique tout ce qui se
passe aux états-unis en france etc
alors on dit que ce sont des
déclarations d'opportunités mais ça crée
un climat d'angoissé qui est profond et
développer un discours pas seulement des
mesures policières
je vous propose de passer à un autre
événement de ce week-end - dramane
heureusement le référendum en catalogne
vous savez que ce cette votation comme
on dit chez nos amis suisses s'étaient
organisés pour ou contre l'indépendance
de cette région
elle se faisait en opposition avec le
pouvoir central puisque madrid avait
bien affirmer que ce référendum et et
illégale donc à essayer de l'empêcher
avec des moyens policiers importants qui
ont été déployés d'où des actes
de violence des affrontements assez rude
qui ont été montrés dans les médias nous
aussi des réactions assez forte des
responsables politiques français pas du
pouvoir exécutif notons le ni le
président de la république ni le
gouvernement ne se sont prononcés sur ce
qui s'est passé hier mais on a vu par
exemple benoît hamon l'ancien candidat
socialiste à l'élection présidentielle
déploré ces images de violence au coeur
de l'europe le l'un des patrons du modem
le parlementaire marc fesneau a lui
aussi envoyé un tweet pour critiquer ce
qui s'était passé hier en tout cas pour
critiquer la position de madrid laquelle
position a été en revanche défendu assez
vivement par l'ambassadeur d'espagne en
france fernando gabeira card herrera
pardon il était ce matin l'invitée du
fil et puis dénoncé clairement des
fraudes massives
écoutez c'est même pas un simulacre de
démocratie ces profs d'une république
bananière et on a vu des zones qui
étaient pleines ban est arrivé au niveau
des fraudes avant avant l'annoncé sur
des fraudes massives
on a changé les règles de vote 45
minutes avant la votation et en quel
pays au monde ont changé les règles de
votre 45 minutes avant une votation
pascal fouda on a surtout vu en france
ces images qui ont suscité beaucoup de
protestations
on n'a pas dit qu'il y avait aussi eu
beaucoup d'abstention dans ce référendum
et que il faisait pas l'unanimité dans
la dans la région oui c'est vrai que la
hausse et là on voit encore le
le poids des chocs des photos et des
images parce que c'est évident que
lorsqu'on voit des personnes qui
souhaitent voter être tirée par les
cheveux violente et pour la première
réaction est une d'une réaction
d'indignation et de rouge est née en moi
visiblement c'est pas que ça puisque bon
les indépendantistes avec qui aurait qu
il y aurait 1 qui dirait au clash
donc il y aurait un bras de fer on y est
bon les propos de l'ambassadeur sont
assez forts de république bananière sur
les moeurs de république bananière et
c'est vrai qu'on ne connaît pas encore
les tenants et les aboutissants
néanmoins c'est l'attitude du
gouvernement et au delà de l'europe sera
importante dans l'est dans les jours à
venir
macron a quand même téléphoné à son âme
à dakar feuilles pour lui exprimer son
attachement à l'unité constitutionnel de
institutionnel de l'espagne donc il ya
ce sera important ce sera un test
et le fait est ce que le gouvernement
espagnol va pouvoir rester sur sa
position ferme et quelle va être la
position de l'europe et ce qui aura
effectué
il
en france où il y aura l'année prochaine
un référendum en en calédonie mais celui
là pour le coup est en or et que mon
égal domaine et crédibles pour parler
vulgairement c'est indémodable sept
dossiers
ça paraît vraiment oui et c'est vraiment
très très obscur et on peut être
pessimiste parce que c'est l'opposition
entre 2 de sons qui appartiennent à la
même famille d'un côté la souveraineté
démocratique un peuple qui veut voter
de l'autre le respect de la règle dans
un état de droit et
lionel ce référendum est illégal ça
c'est clair les les
les catalans eux mêmes ont ratifié la
constitution espagnole qui qui mentionne
que ce type de questions se tranchent
dans un cadre consensuel qui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui avec celle de la nation
donc ça on peut l'opposé c'est pas la
peine comme l'a fait l'ambassadeur
d'aller voir si les gens n'étaient pas
prêts avant le ces peuples c'est pas ça
le sujet c'est pas constitutionnelle et
c'est là que l'ambassadeur ça me frappe
d'ailleurs commet la même erreur que son
gouvernement c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
la ligne qui ce qui ce que l'on ressent
ici c'est une erreur absolument
grossière quelle idée étrange d'envoyer
la police taper sur les gens qui veulent
voter quand le référendum n'est pas
légale en 2014 au référendum de même
type a eu lieu en catalogne
voilà il était il était il était marqué
par l'abstention ça n'avait aucune
valeur s'est développée c'était ensuite
au gouvernement espagnol de traiter de
manière juridique y compris avec
éventuellement des pénalités puisqu'on a
occupé des lieux publics ceux de
d'événements créés par des
indépendantistes qui ont la force des
images pour eux une filiale de disait
vous mettez des braves gens qui veulent
aller voter et l'autre côté du cartable
dessus
la bataille est perdue on se demande
même si c'est pas une espèce de grand
piège médiatique dans lequel serait
tomber un gouvernement démocratique
le cilss oui c'était un piège moi je
pense qu'il faut lire ça aussi par
rapport à l'histoire de l'espagne c'est
à dire que le droit en espagne c'est
aussi l'histoire franquiste et il ya
quelque chose on s'est sorti du
franquisme en reconnaissant au fond le
fédéralisme et donc on n'est pas en
france je suis pas en train de je pense
que c'est très difficile cette situation
est effectivement assez un des merdes
âme comme vous le disiez je pense que la
question de la violence c'est pas
seulement les images c'est que ça
ressuscite aussi des souvenirs par
rapport à l'histoire de l'espagne au
franquisme
je voudrais quand même rappeler une
chose c'est qu'en 2006 la catalogne nu
un statut extrêmement favorable en
termes d'autonomie qui a été remis en
cause par l'international
et je pense que
passé depuis quelques quelques semaines
c'est au fond un resurgissement de chose
qui existe est que nous dans ce qui est
une sorte d'antagonisme bien installée
entre la catalogne et rajoy et qu'il a
voulu gagner à tout prix et que ça
explique l'erreur dont parlait dominique
reynié qui au fond qu'il a joués lire je
veux pas te parler du fir hidalgo mais
enfin il a joué quelque chose qui
n'allait hâte
si les premiers ministres il n'a pas à
jouer les choses en terme de crispation
de cette façon il pouvait tout à fait
laisser laisser les choses arriver mais
ça re se ressusciter des souvenirs parce
qu'en 2006 la catalogne par exemple
avait fait acter le fait que c'était une
nation la catalogne et lui il a fait
invalider sa part le tribunal en 2010 ce
tribunal constitutionnel donc on est
dans quelque chose qui ne s'arrête pas
et au fond il a remis une pièce dans la
machine
alexandre vecchio sur les réseaux
sociaux aux matières yves belle à
theillay nous demandent pourquoi ne pas
traiter la crise catalan comme l'ont
fait les anglais avec les costes a
effectivement il ya eu un référendum en
écosse on les écossais ont voté non tout
ça c'est passé paisiblement
oui mais ça doit se faire dans le
consensus
là ça n'a pas été le cas et même qui est
qui défendent ce référendum sont ceux
qui expliquaient souvent au lendemain du
bric sid qu'il fallait plus faire voter
les gens parce que les gens étaient pas
capables de voter
donc je me méfie de ces terribles il a
s'indigne que l'état espagnol se
défendre en quel que soit son
fonctionnent unité et qui de l'autre
côté ne veulent pas laisser tomber la
grèce est différent derrière le mans
joue quand même un rôle assez ambigu ou
est-ce que le brésil s'était mal et que
la cat et l'indépendance c'est bien
pn qui depuis toujours dans la
construction européenne ont poussé les
régions contre les états et on s'imagine
que cette situation va faire peut-être
hawx est absolument le contraire et
qu'on est dans le problème de la
partition généralisée moi je trouve que
ce qui se passe c'est très inquiétant
tout à l'heure on parlait de l'ouverture
force de faire un monde totalement
ouvert on observe qu'il ya de plus en
plus de frontières et aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui se passe une espèce de replier à
régional et je pense que si on laisse
faire ça on va vers un morcellement très
importants en europe y compris en france
justement quand les états ne cultive
plus leur sentiment d'appartenance on
sont défaillants les gens se replient et
c'est ce qu'on est en ce à quoi on est
en train d'assister aujourd'hui paradoxe
c'est que chez les souverainistes
carlyle
un beau cas d'identité nationale exalté
fondée sur la souveraineté démocratique
c'est le catalanisme et non mais c'est
un vrai sujet qui sont le catalanisme
c'est vraiment une culture nationale ça
c'est vraiment ça jusqu au nationalisme
le plus exalté il est interdit
d'enseigner dans une autre langue que le
catalan alors que c'est constitue
seulement obligatoire de cette enseigne
est aussi un espagnol ils ont recours à
la souveraineté démocratiques et là on
entend maintenant la défense de l'état
nation espagnole
moi je suis pas de jets pas de bise à
cette affaire mais c'est frappant de
voir comment les gens vont dire mes
préférences sont confuses là dessus
parce que non je me rappelle qu'à
renseigner
éval internationaux remis à quelqu'un
dans l'incantation et qu'il faut je
trouvais que la nation qui défend sa
culture aussi culture non et moi menacés
par le risque dans les cales et que vous
étiez présenté aux élections régionales
cette région dans cette région est dans
la m catalogue immense et c'est beaucoup
plus calme heureux c'est vrai qu'une
petite minorité qui voudraient avoir ce
genre de d'horizon mais m est qui et qui
étaient aux arrières objets leur
indépendance
moi j'avais été avec ceux qui n'ont pas
ce pouvoir là mais j'avais dans mon
programme j'avais souhaité nous étions
deux candidats et et l'autre était un
candidat de l'écologie d'ailleurs moi
j'avais j'avais souhaité que l'on
reconnaisse davantage leur culture qui
est une culture riche une vraie culture
c'est comme l'occitan si vous voulez
c'est des vrais langue de leur culture
et apparemment ça n'a pas suffi au
classement espagnol parce que je sais
qu'on a donnée par le passé c'est que la
catalogne est la région la plus riche
d'espagne et qu'en faisant ces 20 % du
pib et que moi je suis d'accord avec
l'idée que l'état nation ça peut être
aussi la redistribution des richesses et
qui a quelque chose qui peut sembler
assez égoïste et dont on ne parle pas
assez en termes économiques et en termes
sociaux dans cette volonté de
séparatisme
et c'est l'espagnol et puis je parle
totalement terminée alexandre ce que je
voulais dire par ailleurs c'est que sur
l'ecosse et est un référendum légal donc
il y avait une vraie différence est que
ça me semble essentiel est que là dessus
la façon dont les robes bijoux
un moment où il faudra que l'union
européenne devienne une puissance
politique face à de telles
contradictions des régions et des états
vous parlez des riches que sont l'état
resté chez les riches avec la repos sur
la fortune vous savez que les frontales
cet impôt était assez largement revues
paraîtront n'est plus considéré n'est
plus concernée part d'ombré l'impôt sur
la fortune que les patrimoines
immobiliers tout le reste est exempté
tout le reste y compris des objets de
luxe comme des yachts et ça choque le
patron du modem et maire de pau françois
bayrou
c'était ce matin sur europe 1 argent qui
s'investit dans les entreprises il est
protégé de la même manière que l'argent
qui s'investit dans le luxe dans l'hyper
confort dans ou dans les coffres forts
puisque les lingots d'or eux-mêmes à
supposer que sont exonérés ça attire les
gens seraient exonérés et comme tout le
monde l'a dit les yachts les les objets
de très grand luxe alors comme ceci
n'est pas juste ceci n'est pas juste
d'amener craignait c'est vrai on aurait
dû remettre dans le sfc objets de luxe
ou bien après tout
mon point de vue là dessus c'est au fond
on actuelle' impôts en france
c'est un peu le procès en hymne oralité
des décisions qui ont été prises
récemment parce que quand on tolère
qu'une majorité de français sur le
revenu une large majorité désormais
c'est en soi suffit de peuples eux quel
français peut dire qui ne doit rien à la
collectivité pour les bénéfices qu'ils
n'en tire en le tolère c'est tout à fait
immoral donc c'est pas la peine ensuite
de revenir chercher le huge 3,48 en
france
le yacht le lingot là aussi je pense que
l'occasion de dire dans trois bars et
transparentes qui nous sommes donc voilà
c'est un c'était trop tard ce débat sur
la moralité l'impôt sur le revenu pour
républicain il y à bien d'autres du tout
et donc pourquoi tout d'un coup faire
surgir des arguments pseudo moreau alors
que nous avons renoncé au caractère
d'intérêt général de cette cet impôt un
furet ya quand même une petite musique
autour de ce thème qui est emmanuel
macron le président geri je fais un peu
oui et s'est étonné qu'on n'est pas
ressorti c'est sa qualité de banquier
jean et rothschild ça ne saurait tarder
mais bon je peux sans tomber dans la
caricature c'est vrai que ça se peut
sembler maladroit
dont 7,7 manière de presque presque une
provocation
c'est vrai quand on revoit les
numérations et d'ailleurs ça a choqué
jusque dans sa propre majorité puisque
on voit que le rapporteur du budget
c'était une mesure qui était un peu
qu'il fallait remettre en question c'est
pas il faut pas être dans la démagogie
mais il faut pas être dans la
provocation non plus je trouve que c'est
vrai que c'est un appeau autour duquel
il ya toujours eu beaucoup de fantasmes
à gauche
néanmois là je trouve qu'il ya quelque
chose ou et qui est de l'ordre un peu de
la la provocation voilà même si c'est ça
ça me concerne pas énormément de
personnes c'est évident mais il oublie
souvent c'est quelque chose d'assez
constant chez lui c'est étonnant de de
parler au peuple c'est quelque chose qui
qui cite une constante et je pense qu'il
faut qu'il fasse attention à ça ça
risque de revenir en boomerang armements
sur deux ans et je crois qu'il va chez
whirlpool demain on peut être qu'on lui
ressortir à ces mesures
alexandre ii vecchio c'est ne pas parler
au peuple que de sortir de l' isf les
les yachts et des lingots de un bidon
j'écoutais françois bayrou je me disais
qu'avec des alliés comme ça nous faisons
donc françois bayrou meilleurs opposants
pour l'instant à emmanuel macron non il
avait tout à fait raison sur le fond je
crois que ça traduit aussi l'idéologie
ma chronique puisque toute l'idée est de
ces ce qui relève de l'immobilier donc
de ce qui est ce qui est permanent et
finalement de ne pas soumettre à l'impôt
les dossiers parce que c'est c'est parti
de ça donc macro se fait le défenseur
d'un capitalisme financier hors sol au
moment même où moi j'ai l'impression que
pour créer des emplois en france il
faudrait plutôt tenté de recréer de
l'inde de faire de l'investissement
productif donc philosophie et comment je
suis pas convaincu je pense que c'est
évidemment injuste mais c'est surtout
très inefficace mais s'ils se mettaient
pas si vous avez un yacht mais est-ce
que vous êtes choqués par par ces
mesures je vais pas choqué sur le sur le
plan du principe mais j'observe qui à du
bricolage fiscal et ça ça m'énerve parce
que je trouve que 80% des ménages qui
sont dispensés la taxe d'habitation puis
de l'autre côté il ya les sf comme
hollande c'est à dire qu'on soit l'on
nous avait promis une grande réforme
fiscale et là on se retrouve avec en
fait une classe moyenne supérieure qui
va se dire mon mais alors c'est moi qui
paye les impôts de tout le monde donc ça
c'est un premier sujet la deuxième chose
c'est que je pense qu'on peut pas
réduire les forces vives en france aux
entreprises surtout quand on fantasme
les entrepreneurs de cette manière c'est
à dire que les actions les obligations
et je pense que l'entreprise je pense
que où les lingots ou les yachts donc
c'est l'entreprise du hautement en tout
cas il ya quelque chose autour de ça qui
est quand même l'idée que l'esprit
d'entreprise
vous savez les fonctionnaires peuvent la
voir les associations peuvent l'avoir et
il ya quelque chose autour de comment
est-ce qu'on libère les initiatives et
la 3 milliards et demi de moins pour le
budget de l'état
question sur les services publiques donc
il ya un truc que j'aime pas en fait
c'est à dire que je trouve qu'il ya ce
bricolage est manière de considérer 3
milliards et demi c'est rien ça me
dérange considéré que les entrepreneurs
c'est ceux qui ont des actions ça me
dérange et considéré que la grande
réforme fiscale on pourra jamais la
faire donc il vaut mieux accumulé des
mesures catégorielles ça me dérange par
rapport à ce que nous avons du maquereau
par ailleurs je suis très sensible à ce
qu'a dit françois bayrou sur la justice
je pense que quand le sentiment
d'injustice commence à poindre
il ya quelque chose qui va pas et donc
il faut très vite installé quelque chose
qui restera un sentiment de justice et
que la réforme donne le sentiment d'être
je sais des personnes qui vont peupler
atteint les invitations qu'ils vont
trouver ça injuste
je pense que ce qu'ils vont trouver ça
injuste c'est les personnes qui payent
l'impôt sur le revenu la taxe
d'habitation et qui ne payent pas qu'ils
ne paient pas liaison des 120 qui existe
dans les sondages vous allez voir par
définition les personnes exonérées de la
taxe d'habitation vont continuer à
trouver injuste qu'on ne surtaxe pas les
lingots d'or on a quand même besoin de
se loger dans d'avoir des la gouvernance
et des favoris c'était un moral mais par
ailleurs pragmatiquement je pense qu'à
terme les gens qui vont se retrouver à
payer les impôts de tout le monde et ça
ça sera un problème parce que c'est
peut-être aussi ceux qui ont élu macro
ne sait toujours pas si c'est bien vous
croyez qu'un changement d'état d'esprit
elle fut la danse
on dit souvent que les français sont
jaloux mais vous le rappeliez il faut
comme élu impression de la république a
travaillé chez rothschild et qui
l'assumé parfaitement qui a gagné
énormément d'argent
est ce que finalement les français sont
pas en train de d'évoluer là dessus non
mais il avait annoncé qu'il allait
supprimer en grande partie des sf
il a été élu quand même oui c'est vrai
nom mais peut-être qu'il ya une
évolution c'est possible
néanmoins bon je pense quand même qu'il
y avait il ya certes un farmall avec les
suis d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit je pense que s'est fixé notamment
les classes moyennes supérieures qui
vont à nouveau être au premier au
premier chef concernée et qui vont
effectivement avoir ce sentiment de 2e
payer alors que les super il mais vont
échapper à certains impôts c'est quelque
chose qui qui va revenir récemment
sinon on fait tout ça ça manque
d'explications et effectivement je suis
d'accord aussi avec ce plan la nécessité
de donner le sentiment que cette réforme
est équitable c'est pas ok qui domine
et je rajouterais que cette expression
de ruissellement à quelque chose de
gênant je vois l'idée effectivement le
chef frédéric américaine qui dit que les
riches comme les chants russes l'argent
ou celle là maurice de russell sur les
pièces d'or voilà comme mais je sais pas
il ya quelque chose que je trouve je
pense qu'il faut expliciter en qu'il
boxe ou et je pense qu'à passer de
coller dans l'opinion pour expliquer
derrière et qu'effectivement du coup on
arrive à une perception qui risquent
peut-être d'être contre-productive et en
tout cas c'est le sentiment de
d'injustice peut être renforcée par une
mesure symbolique certes mais importante
quand même qui est là peut-être la
suppression des allocations familiales
pour pour les familles dites nombreuses
de 2k
je vous propose de nous arrêter sur un
dernier sujet un autre une autre réalité
du week-end même si elle est un peu
parisienne paris sans voiture vous avez
qu'anne hidalgo a interdit la
circulation automobile dans paris toute
la journée d'hier en tout cas jusqu'à
jusqu'à 18 heures je vous propose de
réagir tout de suite et je demanderai
dominique reynié son avis à cet article
de nos confrères d'atlantico expliquant
que la journée sans voiture dans paris
et bien c'était pyongyang sur scène
c'est à dire à la fois une ville vide
comme la capitale de corée du nord
peut-être faute de carburant mais aussi
peut-être une mesure pas totalement
démocratique puisque à 2 quelle avec
quelle légitimité 1ère une mère en
l'occurrence peut-elle interdire ce qui
ressemble à une liberté fondamentale
celle de circuler
c'est une grande question et en
particulier pour la capit paris paris
n'appartient pas à ce point au parisien
c'est une ville française européenne
mondiale par laquelle transite beaucoup
d'activités
beaucoup de personnes passent par paris
pour diverses raisons et y compris bien
sûr beaucoup de personne qui n'habite
pas paris
et c'est une et déjà cette idée que
barry je trouve que c'est frappant çà ça
me choque beaucoup ma part y
appartiendrait aux parisiens qui ne suis
pas parisien est loin s'en faut puisque
on parlait d'impôt ne supportent pas le
coût de la vie c'est la france entière
qui contribuent financièrement haut
standing d'une ville comme paris est
cependant la ville se ferme à ceux qui
ne sont pas en mesure 10 de ciloger je
rappelle que ces 10000 euros le mètre
carré en moyenne à paris pour ça ça me
choque beaucoup pour le coup et puis je
voudrais simplement vous m'avez fait
l'honneur de m'interroger en premier la
question c'est pas paris sa voiture
la question c'est paris sans carbone
et là il ya peut-être une réflexion
avoir un peu plus sophistiqué que la
pure répression ou la gêne occasionnée
pour tous ceux qui sont dépendants de
l'automobile le circuit vous êtes ici la
représentante officielle
défendre cette décision au logis en
marche moi je suis plutôt pour les
journées sans voiture pas seulement je
voudrais quand même dire
qu'effectivement ça relève un peu de la
bulle et que évidemment réduire la place
de la voiture dans notre société c'est
bien autre chose que sans voiture c'est
un peu comme la journée de la femme si
vous voulez lorsqu'il faut faire
l'égalité hommes-femmes s'apprend très
longtemps et on s'est jamais terminée je
suis pas content à journées de la fin
que je pense que comme pour la voiture
c'est quelque chose sur lequel il faut
réfléchir en termes d'organisation
sociale ne pas réduire sa un truc de
bobos et je pense que réduire les choses
à une espèce de bulle qui allaient
jusque sylvain compris le boulevard des
maréchaux et puis en termes d'horaires
c'est au fond se faire plaisir et on est
en fait assez loin d'avoir éclairci les
enjeux qui tiennent au fait de réduire
la place de la voiture c'est à dire
réaménager la ville qu'est ce que veut
dire la voiture électrique par rapport à
ce que disait dominique reynié sur le
sens carbone qu'est ce que ça veut dire
par rapport aux classes sociales dont il
ya beaucoup de choses et en fait on se
fait plaisir comme dans une espèce de
fait un peu utopique qui en plus est
réservé je pense plutôt à des
privilégiés
j'habite la banlieue donc je sais ce que
c'est que être à côté de paris réduire
la place de ma voiture et en même temps
ne pas aller à paris quand il ya la
journée sans voiture on sait plaisir
mais comme tout cas moi ça m'a choqué je
vous le cache pas cette boutique j'ai le
droit de circuler en voiture dès lors
que je ne fais pas je ne met pas en
danger la sécurité de mes voisins face
et s'avoue parapente eu des mots quand
il resterait un poteau pratique c'est un
peu on en sait un peu le bon plaisir de
de madame hidalgo c'est d'autant plus
gênant que est la limite on pourrait
expliquer concevoir dans certaines zones
soient effectivement uniquement réservé
aux piétons
c'est comme le reste des travaux qui
sont engagés les voies sur berge
aujourd'hui c'est un débat très parisien
je suis désolé mais néanmoins à aucun
moment
anne hidalgo de ne nous a expliqué au
nom de quoi il faisait ça pour quoi
vers quels projets elle tendait on ne
sait pas c'est décidé comme ça s'est
imposé à aux parisiens aux gens de la
banlieue
on sait très bien qu'il ya énormément de
conséquences pour beaucoup de petites
entreprises de petits chefs d'entreprise
qui ont des vraies conséquences sur leur
chiffre d'affaires
je trouve qu'il ya une sorte
d'irresponsabilité
assez c'est assez étonnant alors que on
pourrait comprendre aussi on avait des
mesures effectivement chiffre est cadré
et dire voilà on voudrait aller verte
vers cet objectif parce que
comme un vrai problème pour la santé des
enfants pour la santé en général il ya
des problèmes mais on nous explique rien
c'est un s'est imposée d'en haut sans
discussion et sans explication la table
et à entendre alexandre que réagir sur
ce sujet mais je propose d'abord de
faire un petit passage par les réseaux
sociaux en écoutant merouane mais hadji
qui est kivu qui surveille que internet
twitter et tous les réseaux sociaux pour
le figaro bonsoir mais roanne alors
qu'est ce qu'on dit de cette journée
sans voiture ce ne serait pas une grande
nouvelle si je vous disais que nos
internautes sur lefigaro.fr sont contre
la journée sans voiture dans la capitale
et en lisant le millier de commentaires
sur nos articles qui parlent du sujet on
s'est bien amusé à lire vos plaintes
voici un florilège des meilleures
réactions en cinq ans rémy nous dit par
yves saturée entre 15h et 17h
embouteillages monstres aux portes de
paris
allez d'algos pensent peut-être que la
pollution c'est comme le nuage de
tchernobyl ça s'arrête aux frontières de
paris iv troll gentille nous dit on
ouvre les magasins le dimanche ne peut
pas y aller
entre les rues de paris et la corée du
nord il n'y a qu'à
et nous dit eh bien nous autres
provinciaux nous ne comprenons
décidément plus rien aux gens de la
capitale alors que nous bénéficions de
tout le confort moderne eux le rejette
comme andorre 2 va encore plus loin que
la journée sans voiture il nous dit
qu'il préfèrerait un dimanche sans répit
de paris match 44 nous dit enfin max 47
et un internaute taquin il propose pour
la prochaine journée sans voitures dans
l'avenue de la semaine et en faisant un
tour sur twitter j'ai sensiblement vu la
même chose
on a notamment julien courbet qui était
ce dimanche à 15 heures dans les
bouchons en plein paris hashtag la vie
est belle ou encore thomas à l'animateur
d'europe 1 qui écrivait journée sans
voitures mais pas sans ordures hashtag
et priorités et enfin